well i i it's always been my
understanding that
behind the scenes kate has tried very
hard
to forge a reproduction and act as a
peacemaker
between william and harry you know she
loves harry
he said she's the sister that he never
had she's been heartbroken
to see them fall out and i think she is
one of the very few
people one of the few family members who
was actually
able to push the problems together which
you know she did in a very subtle way
but it was very effective and as she
steps back and enables the brothers to
walk together up the hill so i certainly
think she's played quite an important
role
in getting the brothers to the point
where they were able to engage in a
conversation
of course in front of the world's press
everyone was watching the focus of the
day was
absolutely right beyond the duke of
edinburgh this was about
bidding him a fitting farewell
and no one wanted there to be too much
attention
on william and harry and this feud but
inevitably the world was watching we
wanted to see the body language
they were very tense as they walked down
the hill and to the quadrangle when they
entered the chapel
there was no exchange across the aisle
they were seated opposite each other
that's in george's chapel
there was no eye contact and william and
kate had their
gaze firmly on the coffin harriet points
just seemed to be looking
into the distant one only knows what was
going through his head
but that closeness that thawing of icy
relations
certainly took place outside the chapel
and i think many people
felt a sense of relief i certainly did
sitting there
commentating on this really important
occasion
where inevitably there was speculation
on the brothers
i was relieved that that ice was broken
and that here they were
finally shoulder by shoulder and talking
i know that prince harry was very
nervous ahead of coming over to the uk
for the funeral of course this was the
first time he had seen
members of his family in over a year the
last
public engagement where he was with the
senior members of the royal bank
of the commonwealth day service there
have been reports that
prince harry was given the cold shoulder
by some members of the royal family over
here
apparently uh princess anne hasn't had a
huge amount of time for her nephew
prince edward and the countess of wessex
sophia also said to be
still very upset about that oprah
interview
and what was said there is a feeling of
wanting to protect
the queen and a feeling that really
harry has
let the family down there have been some
reports that he'd like to say
for the queen's birthday but it's it's
my understanding that he was
he was due to fly back on monday
possibly those
travel arrangements have changed we're
not being given any guidance for obvious
security reasons but um it's been a
difficult time for prince harry
a part of him wants to stay and of
course be there to support the queen i'm
sure he'd love to be here for her
birthday
but i think there's also a part of him
that is understandably keen to get back
to his
heavily pregnant wife and his little boy